I was talking to this guy and we were
texting and then like the third text in
he said something like oh I'm just
putting the kids to bed with my wife and
I reread it and I went what and then I
went back and he said oh just here for
friends Married with Children and I
thought who's on a dating app to meet
friends
like if you don't have friends and you
don't know how to figure out like red
flag red flag I was like
I'm not talking to you to become friends
okay
I know that was so weird to me and then
I was looking and I guess that's a
category where you can be like I'm just
here to meet people and you're like now
I see that a lot not the married thing
but they hear just her friends and then
I'm like okay well we're all shopping
here
it's full why are you here